buenas buenas tardes buenas noches soy
muy nervioso porque no suelo hablar en
serio arriba a los escenarios pero hoy
voy a hacer un esfuerzo si se quieren
reír pueden reírse también este para
ello sentirme un poco más en el ambiente
pero bueno les platico una vez me
bajaron del escenario sí así como lo
escuchan fue algo muy frustrante muy muy
frustrante te cuento un poco me hablan
para hacer un show en un lugar donde
presentaban donde había música el rock
de los 60 y 70s 19 may queremos meter
comedia entre grupo y grupo qué onda te
animás tiempos deja voy 20 ahorita te va
a subir y te va a ir muy bien entonces
llegó el lugar yo sentí un ambiente
donde a lo mejor no un comediante iba a
ser bien recibido es éste se bajó un
grupo de rock y me subió la misma
persona que me había hablado para ir a
hacer show a los 5 minutos me hace una
seña así como que corta el mix ha sido
muy corta león entonces me bajo y me a
witen no fue una pena enorme porque
aparte todo la audiencia vio que es
me estaba haciendo seguro que cortarle
pues me bajó del escenario agarro mis
cosas muerto de la pena camino entre la
gente porque tenía que salir únicamente
había la salida por entre la gente y con
una llamada o con el viejo truco de la
llamada ficticia así que me salí como
que la virgen me hablaba de chino no
pasa nada mi esposa en ese entonces mi
novia al subirme al carro no tome mi
frustración no me dijo nada después de
unos minutos me abraza y me dice todo va
a estar bien recuerda algo no porque una
noche te va mal eres el peor y no porque
una noche te va bien eres el mejor con
esta plática quisiera yo este y en base
pues a mi experiencia comentarte y ojalá
poder ayudarte para pues como cada no te
puede llevar a un sí ok me dediqué a
ciertas oa muchas cosas
médica a lo largo de mi vida desde los
15 años que andaba picando piedras por
muchas partes y pues bueno para los que
no me conocen ahora si me presento mi
nombre es max al azar orgullosamente
santiaguense
con participaciones en programas de
comedia temprano o más bien con
programas de televisión nacional en
horarios prime time este es uno de esos
sabadazo que salía los sábados fíjate
cómo coincidía eso no es decir lo
específico porque una señora y qué día
sale el programa magaly el domingo
elegido el domingo
mel a tope el día siguiente todo gerosa
la señal yo pensé que estaría como las 6
de la mañana y no saliste na más salió
sabe lo dije bueno pues eso va a seguir
saliendo por los siglos de los siglos
dedicarse a hacer de sus infantiles el
primero si echo simat y les me vestía o
me ponía botargas de esos botargas de
personajes famosos no que tenían tenía
dos ventajas poder ponerme la la botarga
sudaba a chorros no necesitaba hacer
dieta no necesitaba ir al gimnasio y la
desventaja era que pues después la
botarga solían ya para su co
pata sobre cola para los que no sabían
más o menos ese ese término no entonces
este aparte me vestía de payaso me
maquillaba nunca la verdad que nunca
aprendí a maquillarme bien este tipo de
repente yo salía iba a los eventos me
contrataban por una hora yo mismo iba a
poner mis bocinas y todo yo mismo me
acomoda a mi micrófono me disque
maquillada y con ustedes el payasito
mikel y ahí salía yo con mucha energía
siempre los llegó mucha pasión todo que
sí que sí que sí que no que sí que no
que sí que sí que sí que no que sí entre
otras cosas yo salía con mucha pasión
para los tres niños que estaban ahí
porque generalmente los niños andaban en
el brincolín nosotros yo los tres niños
que estaban ellos
y este que onda más porque han perdido
en la actualidad la capacidad de asombro
los niños no me tocaron muchas
experiencias en este tipo de trabajos
porque bueno anécdotas que emite las
imagina si ni yo me imaginaba una vez le
pregunté un niño niño tú quieres quieres
premio y se me quedó viendo así me dijo
la palabra que empieza con p termina con
este sainete un niño de nueve años
aproximadamente yo le quite el micrófono
en friega el hinojo no uno no puede
perder esa esencia no del payaso y no no
al niño no digas es siempre tenía que
estar yo así como que riéndome y no nada
más y ya tengo nada más ya había
agresiones verbales no o sea un niño me
pegó tres veces en una fiesta me pegó
tres veces en el mismo lugar dije este
tres miren el zapato que fred dónde en
el mismo lugar me pegó y como
experiencias o con experiencias como esa
en varias ocasiones ahí viene el primer
no dije no estoy yo la verdad me gusta
mucho lo que hago pero siento que no soy
de aquí y aunque me lleve la facilidad o
perderle el miedo
a hablar por el micrófono el no estaba
súper súper presente
posteriormente dice que otra cosa me
gusta hacer me gusta me gusta en la
actualidad mucho bailar pero en ese
entonces cuando estaba en la prepa
juntos conjunto con unos amigos hicimos
un grupo de baile o mejor conocido como
baile coreográfico en el área
metropolitana de monterrey se usó
muchísimo hace algunos años igualmente
aquí en santiago que habíamos como tres
o cuatro ballets no aquí en santiago
entonces pues asia ponía las
coreografías sin yo ser coreógrafo ponía
las coreografías y que sí que uno y que
dos y que tres y que vuelta y para de
bure y pan de puré no sabía ni cómo se
llamaba realmente los pasos yo ensayaba
las quinceañeras siento desarrollo pero
después veía yo a los ballets que
realmente tenían teoría que sabían
bailar sabían los pasos decían no
manches a yo no tengo la habilidad la
coordinación y el talento que estos
compas tienen o sea era cuando decía no
no siento que yo vaya a vivir en un
futuro en un futuro aunque me gustaba
mucho obviamente no siento que yo vaya a
vivir en un futuro de esto allí aparece
el otro no bueno en parte lo puse yo y
en parte lo puso pues la gente no porque
una vez rifamos un show lo arriba más
así completamente gratis un show y la
señora filón se lo iba a regalar su hija
no en su quince años y la hija se dio
cuenta que íbamos a ir a bailar nosotros
dijo mamani gratis quiero que vayan a
bailar ellos
claro que te frustra no porque no que
paga por otros y que yo conozco unos
amores os cobran 15 mil pesos de vales
mi quinceañera y dice lo pago una señora
prefirió uno de quince mil a uno gratis
imagínate ese no estaba un rotundo ahí
no esté aunque de ese no pues bueno me
llevé la facilidad de moverme en el
escenario entre otras cosas pero él no
está presente todavía el que más hice
bueno fui animador en los los grupos
musicales
en las bodas te ha tocado yo era el que
hablaba entre canción y canción para que
no hubiera un silencio te voy a hacer
una pequeña explicación de lo que hacía
yo no está no sea el grupo cantando de
rosas amarillas pero no para rosa maría
llegaron hoy seguro lo mando uno de sus
admirados y se terminaba la canción más
o menos así
a la gente en lugar de bailar es ya que
me quedo más algo que no sea
es mejor que como 90 millones está
quemando este pequeño china y aunque
aunque lo hacía también con mucha pasión
yo aspiraba para más pues la verdad que
aspiraba para más y eran pocas las
posibilidades este de vivir de siendo un
animador pues de grupos locales no lo
mejor sí pero no sea un grupo intocable
sexual animador no me vale va a pagar
muy bien pero entre éste no lo puse muy
dentro de mí y aparte bueno por fuera de
repente había había no
la comedia siempre me ha gustado desde
muy chico vi muchos programas desde muy
chico comediante donde salía los
programas que los comediantes salían ahí
como te gonzález jorge falcón gilberto
gless que sucederán comediantes que a mí
me han como inspirado para yo de
dedicarme a esto este lo veía mucho y
los primeros chistes que yo hacía las
primeras rutinas que yo hacía eran
meramente rutinas de jorge falcón eran
meramente rutinas de todo gonzález y es
más yo no imitaba a los artistas porque
según yo me ponía ese ese título
imitador pero yo imitaba a gilberto
gless o sea fijate imitaba a un imitador
no entonces poco a poco fui agarrando
experiencia perdiendo el miedo a hacer
chistes para adultos siempre siempre que
los veía y yo decía sabes que yo puedo
hacer eso estos comediantes que te
menciono yo puedo hacer eso yo tengo la
capacidad para hacer eso hacía reír a
mis amigos entre clases de la
preparatoria y de repente les contaba un
chiste y así
y pues bueno
hice muchos shows para fiestas
infantiles y estás más bien de fiestas
privadas de vis hour este despedidas de
cumpleaños entre otras cosas
posteriormente este radicando medio a la
comedia me habla pues una persona de
allende nuevo león y me dice oye mike tú
sabes bailar verdad si es más o menos
porque pues es que éste fíjate qué
pues tengo un puesto aquí mi gimnasio
elige y luego pues quiero que vengas a
dar una clase de zumba
y yo dije inmediatamente elegí no no no
no puedo salir sé bailar pero no sé cómo
dar una clase de suma no pasa nada y
pues internet no te acabes usa dije
bueno vamos a hacer una clase de zumba
no entonces me puso a ver hay unos pasos
y ahí está vídeo que anima chicas ganas
de empezar que le estoy en el cuadrado y
en el cuadrado me mantengo arriba
rodilla o sea yo así este tipo de cosas
este y luego de ahí meramente de ahí
nace la rutina que es como el parteaguas
de mi carrera la rutina que meramente me
cambió la vida
después de hacer un test después de ser
instructor de zumba la misma señora de
ahí del gimnasio me hizo y mike pues
ahora vienen las posadas navideñas pues
a ver si te vienes a hacer un show para
las muchachas dije bueno pues eso sí
porque es a lo que me dedico no
inmediatamente pero cinco minutos antes
de subirme al escenario donde estaban
las muchachas ahí que vean las que iban
a vernos a cenar y ver un show dije que
puedo decirles para que ellas se
identifiquen cinco minutos
así meramente dije oye pues lo que hacen
en la clase de las humano que ánimo
chicas y que lastran damas brinca y que
no sabe que si nos está pasando y así es
que las las que iban por primera vez al
gimnasio se ponían las camisetas de las
campañas políticas porque no tenían este
ropa para hacer ejercicio
entonces pues sí ahí empecé a hacer y le
funcionó muy bien aunque fue una rutina
de tres o cuatro minutos funcionó muy
bien
como hacía nada más shows y privados
después me decían las mismas amigos o la
misma familia oye pues en monterrey
bares de comedia porque no vas a un bar
de comedia a carl arte pues dije sí pues
ya soy comediante tengo que ir a un bar
de de comedia llegué al unicornio azul y
ha conocido a nivel nacional
internacionalmente
llegué yo y bien fregón dije me gusta me
den chance de subirme al escenario
porque soy comediante muy amable me
dijeron está loco qué chingados está
pasando porque aquí necesita venir dos
semanas primero a ver y luego
posteriormente ya subirte para que no
choques con ningún comediante puede no y
que no tengo las dos semanas fui las dos
semanas de es posteriormente las dos
semanas me dan solamente 15 minutos para
hacer mi audición en este bar de comedia
para mi fortuna van seis personas salvar
esa de público
4 eran mi familia y dos eran alguien
como que no sé no tenía nada que hacer y
fueron al bar y las otras dos personas
que estaban atrás que no cuentan como
públicos sino como jueces eran los
dueños del unicornio azul que se sabían
todos los chistes habidos y por haber
pues muy mal o sea no me bajaron en esa
vez del escenario pero los 15 minutos
que me dieron yo mi nerviosismo y porque
mi familia ya se sabía los chistes que
yo traía de hecho lugar de apoyarme me
dijeron ahí esté otra vez lo va a contar
o sea éste
entonces entonces pues muy nervioso hoy
gracias por darme la oportunidad y la
frase típica es nosotros te hablamos no
y no no me hablaron yo tenía que estar
existiendo y gander mi oportunidad por
favor bueno pues fue una noche ahí este
me puse muy nervioso de mi oportunidad
de una oportunidad no es que pues no
tenemos presupuesto digo no quiero que
me paguen no quiero que me paguen
simplemente es más yo invierto yo tenía
que invertir desde aquí en mi casa a tu
casa hasta cumbres que era donde estaba
este donde está este bar y pues
aproximadamente son 45 minutos y en ese
entonces podrán invertir para pagar
gasolina gasolina ida y venida y aparte
si también este yo me solventaba mis mis
gastos como facultad y todo desarrollo
dijo en ese entonces todavía vivía con
mis papás siempre he tenido el apoyo de
mis papás stem entonces me da la
oportunidad después de dos o tres veces
me va muy bien gracias a dios en una en
una ocasión el unicornio azul y me dan
la planta
de estar allí dos o tres veces por
semana la zumba la rutina ya mencionada
pues era para mí el como la punta de
lanza no era mi carta fuerte yo sentía
que cuando hacía yo esa rutina había
muchos picos de risa igualmente yo me
sentía muy a gusto contando la
el dueño del unicornio azul decide subir
las redes sociales y después de unos
meses se empieza a compartir en facebook
llegan más de 100.000 compartidos en
facebook y millones y millones de
reproducciones sin yo darme cuenta
yo tenía aproximadamente tres o cuatro
años dedicándome a la comedia y en mi
página de facebook tenía 2000 likes osea
en esos cuatro años sabía yo reunió son
2000 likes después de una semana cuando
empieza para pegar el chiste de la zumba
pues bueno 100.000 compartidas y subía
100 mil seguidores pero era que decía yo
por qué y de dónde no entonces ya me doy
cuenta que se empezaba a compartir me
hablaban personas de eeuu familiares que
mencionó y hay una rutina un chiste tuyo
que está por acá y pegando muy fuerte y
todo desarrollo dijo oye pues que a todo
dar
o sea que éste esta rutina que salió de
algo a lo que me dediqué pues bueno este
meramente este medio pues una carta para
ello mostrarle y así
y así si así lo puedo decir en muchos
estados de la república y en eeuu es a
esa rutina ha sido como que la llave en
muchas puertas este y te digo que
gracias 12 se me han abierto no entonces
ahí fue cuando yo dije por fin llegó un
sí a mi vida por fin después de varios
no sí que obviamente poco a poco aprendí
de eso no y aunque eso no me dejaron
algo bueno el primero lo mejor me me
dejó perder el miedo al escenario al
micrófono el segundo que era de bailar
pues me enseñó a lo mejor a moverme en
el escenario como actualmente éste lo
hago y que creo que lo hago bien no se
ha quejado es de la gente de eso
entonces
fuera de que no aunque pues obviamente
sea negativo o suene negativo volvernos
poco a poco son peldaños creo yo para
llegar al si yo quiero comentarte
preguntarte si no has llegado a dónde
quieres llegar y cuántos no crees que te
falten para llegar al fin me presento en
los ángeles california que creo yo que
cada persona que nos dedicamos a
subirnos a la tarima a ir algún día los
ángeles california ese pues como que una
satisfacción no
terminó de hacer el show en el million
dollar fire que es un teatro de los más
emblemáticos para los latinoamericanos
en eeuu
y precisamente para los mexicanos
gracias lo llenamos fue un soldado
completamente
terminó el show me subo a la camioneta y
de la camioneta al bien del teatro al
hotel iba mi esposo a un lado me
acompaña mi esposa se me quedó viendo y
me abrazó y me dijo
te dije que todo iba a estar bien pero
recuerda no porque una noche te va mal
eres el peor y no porque una noche te va
bien eres el mejor como que aterriza te
también y vienen muchas cosas todavía
mejores muchas gracias qué amables
[Aplausos]